KATU in South Africa lies in the
Kalahari Desert and is the iron ore
capital of the region most of the town's
eleven thousand residents work in the
mining industry five years ago iron ore
was still in demand the mining companies
flourished and so did the town but then
demand for the raw material dropped and
work slowed Adele Razoo grew up in cotu
her family has long worked in mining and
she remembers many good times she works
for the trade union solidarity and
spends a lot of time out in the
community these days she's often the
bearer of bad news I know has been the
hardest hit of all the community at
commodities since June last year I've
handled more than 6,000 retrenchments
retrenchments or job losses are the big
fear here kumba iron ore one of the
biggest iron ore producers in Africa is
planning to cut 4,000 jobs in KATU
massive cost cuts are needed all over
South Africa some 32,000 jobs are said
to be under threat the big problem is
the industry's dependency on China more
than half the iron ore mined in KATU
previously went to China but demand has
now plummeted this whole town has been
built upon the iron ore mines so the
impact is huge
nearly everyone here is affected shops
are having to close for lack of
customers many office buildings are now
empty and prices for real estate have
nosedived here you can see another full
sale sign at a lost union meeting a
member came to me with tears as he just
bought a house for 1.6 million last year
and the bank now valuated digital
500,000 so he's not going to be able to
sell that property the story is the same
all over cotu and in many other mining
towns in South Africa other companies
that only benefited indirectly from the
mining wealth like the construction
industry are also packing up and leaving
Alan secombe is a correspondent for
business day South Africa's leading
business daily he says he's never seen
anything like it Katoon is a microcosm
of what's happening to commodity based
economies around the world it really is
a boom-or-bust situation we're in the
good times the economy grows monies
generated people employed and NASA me
it's dan turn people are leaving cotu
the jobs have been cut there's a lot of
despondency and we can see this in our
neighboring countries in southern Africa
Zambia and go to the economy is on the
verge of collapse later we attended a
trade union meeting in cotu everyone
here is worried about their job the
meeting is emotionally charged the
response is very from anger to despair
hip knee on the boss on that we don't
know what's going to happen we're left
in the dark we just want to know so
belief means obvious please sleep will
be patient I know it's hard and I
understand your emotions we're all in
the same boat take a deep breath and
we'll keep you informed we live now
in in fear of spending any things you
always will you go to the Chop sake okay
well if I don't have a job tomorrow what
if I don't have that tomorrow whatever I
don't know that so you'll be living
enough in the semi state of feel almost
one hundred percent of the time Adele
rasu has little hope to offer I don't
know what the options are I don't know
where these people are going to go if
they get retrench currently in South
Africa all the mining all the commodity
prices are under pressure so I cannot
tell a member that you should go to
platinum or gold or that because there
is employment opportunities in Adele
Russell's trade union most of the
members are white mosop ad Davidson on
works for another trade union that
fights for the rights of the black
workers the union's meet regularly and
work together closely all the union
members are worried about their jobs and
their families an employee one employee
in the mind represent a huge family of
people so 4,000 people to be retrenched
that simply means 40,000 people out of
the number of people who are working at
the mine will be affected by this
process of our very transmit the poorest
in KATU are being equally hard hit many
work for subcontractors linked to the
mines Joseph qett see is a bricklayer
he's just lost his job he says the
compensation he'll receive for being
made redundant won't last long after i
get them maybe maybe rich rich media
naked metaphor maybe he doesn't rent
after that it doesn't and I have no
American eat now big mines are not
helping people di just here to make
profit and take what they want to take
left damn people here and then go we
repeatedly asked kumba iron ore what
they plan to do for workers in KATU but
got no reply Adele Rasool feels it's a
losing battle she too is affected as her
husband also works in the mind first
thing we will lose this house this is a
my house so if you get something if you
get arranged we no more house and so all
across South Africa people are hoping
the prices for raw materials will go up
again and then things will improve